this weekend marks one of the first
major holidays since vaccinations began
in kate houston showing us how churches
across the valley
are preparing for easter services and
families are getting ready to hug loved
ones they haven't seen for months
it's been a whole year since we've
really had the ability to get together
and celebrate without
added anxiety or added precautions
marcella williams is eagerly awaiting
easter sunday when she'll finally get to
see her in-laws and nieces
now that most of my
adult extended family has received at
least the first dose
it's just a huge sigh of relief i can
literally feel the anxiety reducing in
my body
williams says this weekend will be an
opportunity to start seeing people again
and feel some normalcy as a family while
some will be staying home this weekend
many will also be preparing for easter
sunday church services
this sunday is just so special jeremy
and lindsey bosma run avenue church in
the southwest valley
they're anticipating 500 people will
attend their easter sunday services
churches all over are taking the
precautions to welcome people there
on easter sunday so i think it's going
to be a win across the valley for all of
us
the bosmas say this sunday marks the
first time some of their congregation
has worshipped in person
since the pandemic started not having
easter
last year being totally online but now
in person there's just something about
community there's just something about
you know seeing someone although six
feet away having community and to be
able to
do life together on sunday after a year
that highlighted the mental health
challenges of isolation
williams says she can't wait to finally
hug her family
and friends coming together as a
community is just a great reminder that
we will always be vegas strong
kate houston 8 news now many houses of
worship were forced to adapt really
quickly to safety guidelines and some
started live streaming their services
this sunday avenue church and others
across the valley
will offer a live stream of their easter
worship